hi this is tara i'm from long beach
california
so my question is um i'm a family
physician who works full-time
i have twin three-year-olds and i
am trying to dabble in ultra running
my wife is supportive of my running but
in a way that can be frustrating and
difficult for our relationship
so my question is how do i best balance
these three things that i have going on
without disrupting the balance of my
relationships as well
specifically with longer runs on the
weekends and time away from family
what is a good way to address these
issues and have everyone's needs met
thanks guys bye um this is a great
question i think this is
relatable for anybody who uh
gets involved in endurance sports you
know the the the term
uh uh iron man widow uh exists for a
reason
oh really because these pursuits can
often end in
cataclysmic relationship results if not
handled appropriately i figured you are
the perfect person to ask this question
well it's not easy i mean this is the
first thing i would say
is is you're set up for failure right
out of the gate
because this is a very difficult hat
trick to
accomplish and i think
to launch into this the first thing to
bear in mind is you can't excel at all
of these things
every single day like there's this idea
of how am i going to balance all of
these things so that i'm
giving them an appropriate amount of
attention every single day
and i think that's the wrong way to
think about it because you can't do that
you can't be at your best
as a physician as a partner as a parent
and as an athlete all the time like it's
just not rigged that way
so let go of that fantasy out of the
gate
and try to configure a schedule and a
structure
that allows you to kind of toggle
between these pursuits understanding
that on certain days
your priority is going to be in one of
these buckets
or two of these buckets but not all of
these buckets
so that over the course of a month or a
week
they're all getting an adequate amount
of attention but not all
on the same day or at the same time so
structure and scheduling
super important i think that you should
craft that schedule
um in cooperation in partnership with
your
wife so that your wife is part of
organizing
what these days are going to look like
that your wife is participating
in the allocation of of
you know your time and energy and to
come to that conversation trying or
endeavoring to the best of your ability
to structure your training at periods of
time
that don't compromise the goals that
your wife has or the parenting needs
that you both mutually
share so that might mean that your runs
have to be
super early in the morning before
anybody's awake or late at night when
everybody's asleep and i understand that
you have a full-time job
uh you're not a professional ultra
runner though right nobody's paying you
to do that this is something you choose
to do
but you've got to make the choice of how
you apply that
in a way that's not disruptive to your
family you already know that
and that means you know finding those
windows of opportunity
that don't uh put you know your wife's
schedule
apparel and create this tension in the
relationship
the other thing is you don't want to
ever set yourself
up to be over trained or overly fatigued
you've got to be able to show up 100
for your kids and for your wife when
you're not training and you're not
working
so that so that that doesn't become an
additional drag on top of the hours
spent when you're not at home
and i think what's been helpful to me
in doing this is twofold first
anticipate your wife's needs and your
kids needs
in in advance so that you're planning
for that
and you're not like showing up you know
oh you didn't get the groceries because
you had to go running or something like
that
these are the things that like are small
things in isolation but they add up and
they they can really
you know derail a relationship right so
being ahead of the curve in terms of
um understanding and anticipating what
your wife is going to need and and
and fulfilling those needs before
perhaps she's even aware that she needs
them filled so that way
you're demonstrating through your
behavior repetitive behavior
that you're conscious of the fact that
you're ultra running is perhaps taking
you away from the relationship more than
she would like but you're showing up in
ways
that um are telling her like you're here
right even when you're not there you're
actually there and then when you are
there to be
a hundred percent like when i was
training for ultraman at my peak
i've told the story before but you know
i come back from like a 30 mile run or a
you know six hour bike ride and i'd walk
in the house like just
waste it and julie would like hand me a
baby and be like you're turned by
you know i'm gonna go do my thing right
and i couldn't be like i need a nap or i
gotta like shower
it's like no you gotta be on point right
it's your turn
and by respecting that and making sure
that
i was present when those you know
moments arose
that's how we were able to kind of keep
everything moving and on track if i was
just like no i can't or
or um sorry i gotta train right now like
that's not gonna work
so were there times where she pushed
back against
like well she was very surprised i mean
i was lucky because i had a very
supportive
she's all about you finding like like
right
and that doesn't mean that it wasn't
hard because we're talking about a ton
of time and also
you know we were going through some
financial state it was like a very
difficult period and
and you know i credit julie tremendously
for
for really you know being an incredible
support in a way that i think most
partners
um wouldn't and can't be expected to
honestly so
it's understandable like what you're
going to go run for fi
like we we have we have twin baby like
what are you doing you know like
you got to be here so that's why
i think anticipating your partner's
needs and the needs of your children is
so
important i also think that you have to
choose your moments
like i said at the outset it's
impossible to excel at all these things
every single day and if you attempt this
you're going to fail in all the
categories
you're not going to be able to train
like a pro so don't try to
and there's going to be days where maybe
you have some
big run on your calendar and this is
really important to you but
something went haywire at home and the
kids need you and you got to be like i
got a [ __ ] what are my priorities like i
got to show up for my kids i got to show
up for
my wife like what is most important in
the grand scheme of things
is it really worth derailing your
relationship for ultra running like
ultra running is something you can do
your whole life if you do it responsibly
um
and so that doesn't mean that that your
needs shouldn't be met
either it's important if this is
bringing you happiness and fulfillment
that you should have the freedom and the
the license to like do the things that
you enjoy doing which is why
communication is so important right and
if this is important to you
it's incumbent upon you to communicate
the importance
of it to your wife so that she really
understands like does she really
understand
why is this important to you why are you
doing this
and the more that you can have that
channel of communication
open with your wife i think you'll be in
a better place to
engender the empathy and support that
that you're looking for
but that's a two-way street you got to
give it in return as well you can't
expect her
to support you unless you're supporting
her in kind so
what is it what is her what is your
wife's ultra running like what is it
that she would like to be doing
and how can you go out of your way to
make sure that you're
supportive to her in that regard in the
way that you would like to be supported
it's great advice um i can't offer
anything
to really to this discussion other than
that because i'm not doing 30 minutes
you have a baby and you're trying to do
this goggins thing and you've got a
people at home so how's that going i had
to talk
i had to talk her into the goggins thing
she was not really feeling the goggins
well because for her she's like with the
baby
almost all the time and um i have my
work which at least allows me
even if i'm in the same apartment i'm in
a psychic space that is my own
and she's not really permitted a psycho
psychic space that is her own
too often and so when i run training
often i'll take the baby out with me
as a stroller run right that was the
other thing i had on my
uh list of things to respond to like get
the get the
twin you know um baby carriage thing
yeah
it's called i haven't had babies in a
while yeah stroller yeah
it's been a while but they're still
called strollers and you know
she lives in long beach there's like
those paths along the the ocean you know
where you can like push a stroller and
pretty soon they can ride bikes
alongside you or whatever but
so i did have to talk her into that and
just and it just took that i
explained to her why it was important to
me as best i could even though i
couldn't really explain to you while
important to me but
but she understood that she never didn't
want me to do it it doesn't really show
up as much in the running
because for me most of my runs are a
little over an hour
um sometimes less sometimes a little
over an hour and if i want to do a long
one for me it's like a 10 mile
run usually so that's like it's it's not
it's not like a 30 mile run
but swimming um at least doing the dives
in malibu
that has become a lot less frequent than
it used to be for me i try to get us out
there once a week but that includes
taking everybody out getting a beach
tent set up doing the whole thing
otherwise
as somebody who who who participated in
that with you i can
i can affirm that that is a languishing
affair
that goes on for hours unnecessarily i'm
like are we gonna swim and get this done
what are we doing we're looking for our
octopus teacher
yeah i'm like i'm out for a workout and
you're looking for octopus
yes that's right we're we're getting in
touch with our lyric escape yeah
i'm like no wonder she's like what are
you doing well she comes out with us so
she's only been able to she went one
time it's
she doesn't like 55 degree water so for
her it's like if the viz is good and
it's
warmish she's down and so i have we have
made it possible for her to go with the
group and then i
i did my own thing after we've done that
once but
it does take like i can't expect her to
go sit on the beach when the wind is
howling and
it's getting sandblasted with the baby
while i go on a little swim so
that is not happening as often as it
used to uh
but she loves the beach also so she
likes being out there so it's really
about
the communication aspect is important
and you do have to kind of
sublimate especially knowing that i have
four by four coming up
basically after four 4x4 she prefers
kind of workout
mat workouts with this trainer from our
gym that we no longer go to because of
the pandemic
um and so we've been having him help us
sometimes and
and after the 4x4 48 we're going to
prioritize more of those workouts that
she can do
um and and then i'll i'll do you know
and so we're just doing that so that's
kind of the thing she wants to do
to you know how am i supporting her in
kind that's the next step so
my running i probably do little less
mileage every month and build in this
other
strength aspect and that's just how it's
going to have to be because you can't do
it all
right
[Music]
you